sure um okay so you guys are i want to  ask both of you are live on are you  keeping the camera up when you guys are  playing  no  i don't really want to see magnus  and then i guess the same answer for you  minus you're not keeping the cameras up  uh i wouldn't say um  that there's a like a definite rule but  i would say more often than not i don't  see my my opponent it actually  um i got tricked once by nakamura when  he was shaking his head  and i thought he'd made a blunder but he  actually tricked me instead so after  that i've been really  um  yeah i've been really careful about not  um yeah not trying to to read something  from from my opponents  all right and then we did hear lavon  here he summed up your four draws today  uh what do you say magnus how did you  feel the games were going  yeah i think it was pretty  uh pretty fair